Bladesmiths, welcome
to our strength test.
One of my favorites,
the ice block chop.
And we supersized it.
What I'm gonna do is
take each of your swords,
and I'm gonna beat them
repeatedly and viciously
into this big chunk of ice.
It's gonna test the overall
construction of your sword,
as well as its
edge-holding ability.
Now, what your
swords do to the ice
is secondary compared to what
the ice does to your swords.
And John, you're up first.
How you feeling, buddy?
Nervous.
Well, we're
gonna do it anyway.
Yeah.
[grunting]
[music playing]
Oh.
[laughing]
[music playing]
Well, this is very heavy,
very hard to control.
Also, aside from having
gaps in your shoulders here,
you've got a pretty
good bend in the blade,
and that was there
before I started.
Not a lot of edge
left, but you survived.
Drew, how you feeling?
I'm ready.
Good, so am I.
[grunting]
[music playing]
[suspenseful noise]
Now, Drew, this is
a beautiful sword.
Thank you.
The blade is
still razor sharp,
which is very impressive
with an ice block chop.
That being said, the ice block
chop is meant to be brutal.
It's meant to test the overall
structural integrity of
your sword, from tip to pommel.
Problem is, I'm holding
your pommel in this hand
instead of this hand.
So that's an issue.
Yeah.
Drew, your blade has suffered
a catastrophic failure.
I have to ask you to
please leave the forge.
DREW: I'm sad that
my blade failed,
but I feel really
good about the fact
that I was able to make
something completely
outside of my wheelhouse.
But none of that matters if
the pommel comes flying off.
If the functionality
isn't there,
the aesthetics
really do not matter.
I had a ton of fun.
I would do it again in a second.
I'm super excited to get
back to the west coast
and just get back
to work chipping
away at my custom orders.